welcome to this video playing zom zom
2263 and it's a calc on with h form huh
yeah h5 you need to attend to his
threats like g4 yes this move him this
had been played against me this I was
played against me before and
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait why cannot take you for Queen have
night ah what dag Bishop f5 25 is
winning so it's probably Knight f3 and
Queen g4 okay let's just see what
happens it's probably a trap or
something that i don't know but i don't
i don't quite see it at the moment haha
mmm interesting ok
so I wanna pawn but my queen is really
weird on g4 queen bee three attacking b7
I have queen before unfortunately
unfortunately um yeah I'm really now I
need to I need to get the Queen back
this is just too weird on g4 so one what
is this position I grabbed the porn but
it is somewhat somewhat undeveloped
position I don't have anything developed
so wyd certainly has gotten compensation
not sure how much but it's it's it's
something tangible it's not not nothing
could have played in f6f six is somewhat
trapping this bishop but it's 96 m 2mon
turn that probably
peugeot night eh I'm threatening f6
probably maybe I can provoke him to take
on his heaven I mean this all looks very
slow and I've got nothing developed or
fine but it's a very close position he
cannot easily open it without the sea
porn here doesn't have c4 prying open
the goo inside yeah this is the only
will leave a left yeah okay MF six let's
win this bishop it's um it's something
yeah I don't see anything else need to
grab the material and hope to not get
mate it yep of course but I don't really
believe it I have I can Castle long this
is this is not this is some one of those
sacrifices that don't really work but
still need to be refuted it's something
that works for example or any computer
with really easily diffuse but um it's
not so easy in the practical game if I
take Queen g4 maybe yeah but why not why
not 24 i can even just retreat this I
have thought I have night f form with
further exchanges and then after the
trade if it really takes on a flight
resign yes that's really nothing if he
takes Queen takes I start to threaten on
h2 I rather quickly get the attack here
yeah it was just not working but I think
he had very very significant
compensation here this is certainly new
stink position for wide maybe a move
like I don't know quindi three or
something the idea that after f6 you
have from have maybe him have 92 g six
this is very good for white probably
wins so I cannot play of six and then I
probably go here something like that
intending 95 yeah white has got those
active nights this is some compensation
I'm not sure if it is enough but it's
it's something I may be here oops move
like that here this looks unplayable yep
can take him check so I need to go here
takes and then not sure Queen deform
probably this G for you I love this
chance this evening this evening what
okay so I need to I need to cover here
or be back yeah I don't know a very
complex position White has gotten the
spawn back and still the active nodes
but this is a weakness and I'm ready to
to evacuate the King very unclear
position I don't know this this is fake
very very strange line maybe I can take
me to what so it's very very strange
yeah i don't know i need to do i would
need to look that up in a book or the
database of this is an online maybe this
it looked dangerous thanks for watching